why don't we speak next just because
we're doing it and we have time let's
speak to Michael from New Jersey Michael
from New Jersey welcome to the David
Pacman show what's on your mind today
Michael from New Jersey please accept my
invitation to appear on my program
and last chance for Michael from New
Jersey
all right well that's too bad really
seem to want to get on why don't we go
next to I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly is it saan from Israel cyan
uh it's Sean thanks for having me oh
it's Sean wow I've never seen Sean
spelled that one uh yeah my mom she's uh
she's Irish so that's how this spell
love it all right well what's going on
uh I'm from uh well I'm from Israel uh
it's a touchy subject right now but so
your mom is an Irish Jewish person
uh no she's Catholic but near my dad or
my mom's uh our religious I mean I grew
on the kibbutz are you familiar with it
of course yeah but so hold on a second
neither of your parents is Jewish but
you were brought up no no my dad is uh
safaric Jewish okay
[Music]
no I had I had never heard of non-people
with no Jewish parents growing up on
kibutsim that's but you said your dad is
Jewish got it yeah I mean well she also
volunteered the kibauts so that's how
they met but uh so yeah but
um other than that I thought maybe
um you know if if there's a such thing
because I know there's a commune in the
U.S and it's usually it has this best
stigma because most of the time in U.S
it's like a short bad reasons but I
thought you know like but the kimbots
it's like one of the like great example
that actually worked for us really well
actually you know like
if it gets some Implement some elements
of that and kind of like or or prove it
in some ways because
are interesting and they're often used
as case studies for look this is an
example of a pseudo-socialized commune
type community that really works well I
think there are a couple of things Sean
that are often said in response to that
one is the do you know like what's the
largest kibbutz how many people are part
of the largest kibbutz
um not much to be honest I didn't really
follow I mean I know my kibbutz doesn't
do well these days because they did some
bad decisions the last parts of their
lands or something but I guess what I'm
getting at is the the two most common uh
rebuttals to the idea of the kibbutz is
proof of communal organization is one
kibutsima relatively small often 150 or
fewer people and and even with the
bigger ones which maybe are in the 500s
I think that you're really getting to
the upper reaches of when that sort of
organization makes sense and so a lot of
times people say sure do it with 15 000
people and you'll see it no longer make
sense which of course isn't really the
point of the kibbutz that's one thing
that's that's often said
um the other thing that's often said is
you know it's a bit of a cop-out to look
at the kibbutz as the proof of the
commune living because it doesn't stand
on its own it exists Within the state of
Israel and all of the benefits and
infrastructure that the state of Israel
provides so it's not really a good
example of self-sufficiency the counter
to that counter would be actually a lot
of these kibutsim are quite
self-sufficient so it's it's a it's a
conversation that takes place I think
both sides have interesting perspectives
yeah and yeah I also like all like do
like exact same first I mean like well
okay what's it sound like uh like a new
thing it's it's it's just a sort of like
like yeah it's like a strong Martin
version I guess of a cameo and it's not
new it's not like uh it's really
mentioned but
um I thought like I don't know maybe we
could take some elements of it or or
improve it in some ways you don't need
to I agree I mean listen there's been a
lot written about some of the great
things uh that that you see at kibbutzem
including the sort of community child
rearing that takes place where people
watch out and participate watch out for
and and help to raise all children in
the community
um the the safety there's a lot of
things I think that are that are
interesting regardless of your views on
Socialism or capitalism or whatever I
mean I guess that's why I'm more I guess
more in the socialism Vibe I mean
because I'm more that's I'm more
familiar with it it doesn't make sense
yeah I mean was grown was not religious
like to sell hams all that
all right and uh remember every time you
swear our producer has to bleep it so
let's try not to not to do that sorry
Sean listen it all sounds incredible I
really do appreciate you calling in
today
all right have a nice day all right
there goes Sean from Israel we almost
squeaked through today with no bleeps
but Sean got us he really did all right
everybody that's gonna do it for today
we will take calls again and I hope you
are one of the next people I speak to